je m'appelle Jérôme je suis au rsa
depuis 8 mois et j'ai un projet
d'entreprise dans la réparation
automobile mon conseiller insertion
m'oriente vers le réseau Point chance et
j'appréhende plus facilement toutes les
démarches de création d'activité une
fois mon entreprise créée avec mon
conseiller insertion du département je
fais la demande de R + la location
d'insertion et de retour à l'emploi
grâce à ce dispositif mais allocation ne
baisse pas r+, progresse tous les six
mois avec mes revenus d'activité et me
permet d'investir pour développer mon
entreprise après trois ans d'aide je
peux me verser un salaire de plus de
1600 euros par mois R+ l'activité en
toute sécurité plus d'informations sur
www.département974.fr